players that we would like to see win a
super bowl in the national football
league we are dispensing with the trivia
i'm taking the first question there's a
damn thing you can do about it sims and
this one is easy for me this one is
obvious we almost saw him win one
12 years ago it was the first super bowl
i ever personally attended it looked
like the cardinals were going to pull
off the victory after fitzgerald was
shot out of a cannon i want to see larry
fitzgerald get his fingerprints on a
lombardi trophy before he retires and
hopefully the cardinals are moving in
the direction of making that happen yeah
i hear you i mean that was going to be
one of my two picks there's no doubt
about it so uh makes a lot of sense and
i would love to see that as well you
know you want to see the spirit of this
draft is guys that you know have put
their heart and soul and done everything
they've done right or done everything
right to put themselves in a place to
try to win a championship and larry
fitzgerald i mean come on who who you
know it says that more than him all
right well i'm going phillip rivers you
know same thing here you know damn i'd
love to see philip rivers win a super
bowl certainly i mean he's one of the
toughest players toughest quarterbacks
in the history of the sport
competitor backs down from no one you
know never makes excuses
i just think there's a lot to really
respect about phillip rivers i would
love to see it you know it's it's it's
one of those things this year where
you know between hey it's easy to root
for frank reich it's easy to root for
chris ballard and now you got phillip
rivers i feel like i'm in like you know
this one's for john i feel like this is
like one of those years where i'm gonna
become a colts fan a little bit because
i like philip rivers and like to see him
uh maybe get that final championship to
cap off his career
if he just gets to a super bowl and
doesn't win it is that enough to get him
into canton um
maybe in this era of inflated numbers
i think there might be a chance because
you know i know we were talking about
before the break he's about to pass dan
marino for all-time passing yards you
know and it's a different era altogether
but i think if he
if he just got to the super bowl i'm
going to say probably no i think he
probably needs a win at this point to to
solidify the hall of fame i think it's
going to be very debatable if he just
gets there
next one for me a guy not around in the
nfl as long as philip rivers or larry
fitzgerald but a guy who was in a super
bowl whose team was favored to win the
super bowl unable to pull it off and now
joining a team that knows a thing or two
about believing i can't believe you're
picking them i can't believe you're
picking him
i know you are why i'm mad because i
wanted to pick him
that's why i picked him you could have
picked him instead of philip rivers damn
cam newton and we have a story about him
showing up at the airport last night now
look the social media post from cam
newton since he was signed by the
patriots not exactly the patriot way
cam newton showing up
at the airport last night
definitely the patriot way i don't want
to disrespect anybody but i got nothing
to say that's the patriot oh yeah and
cam newton just kept on walking yeah
that's great yeah you know that'll
that'll go over big with that team up
there and especially bill bill will like
that that he set the tone like that
right there and uh yeah i mean like we
heard rodney harrison talking yesterday
we got a man on a mission right now as
far as you know playing quarterback and
cam newton and all that all right um
ooh i'm torn i'm a little torn sorry
sorry i blew up you're driving you're
totally you totally killed me there i'm
i'm four for four this week you're gonna
have to come back tomorrow
you're driving yeah it was so horrible i
don't even know what to talk about i'm
gonna go awesome i'm going with jj watt
all right i'm gonna go with jj yeah i
mean come on the guy's
you know one of the best defensive
players of our generation
been another guy that's been stand up
off the field been really good with a
lot of causes and you know it's a
dominant force you know been through had
some tough injuries but you know jj watt
hands down first ballot hall of famer
one of the greatest defensive players in
the history of the sport he's already
solidified those type of things to be
said with his name so i would love to
see him and dion you know deshaun watson
and billy o'brien hoist the trophy at
some point that would be pretty cool
yeah jj watt three-time nfl defensive
player of the year first battle hall of
famer and and just a team that that that
has never been able to put it all
together i agree with you that's not a
bad choice next one for me and i got a
lot of other names on the list hopefully
we'll be able to rattle some of them off
i'm gonna go
i'm torn here i'm torn
but but one of my picks has played in
one
the next guy hasn't played in one
i got to go adrian peterson
adrian i forgot about him around since
2007
uh and uh almost got there in 2009 and
he was one of the reasons why the
vikings lost that game they outplayed
the saints that day but he fumbled a
couple of times in bad spots killed
scoring drives but you know he just
keeps going he may not be on the ideal
team
to get to a super bowl this year
especially since washington comes in at
number 32 on our pre-season power
rankings but i'd i'd love to see him get
to a super bowl and win one chris yeah i
would too i mean you know hey it's
uh you've heard me said i think he's the
greatest when he was in his prime when
we're talking first seven eight years of
his career i i never saw a running back
better in my life you know since i've
been alive i know that that's you know a
bold statement but i mean just i i've
told the stories i know you've heard me
say it i mean when i was on the field
with him for the first time in a real
game and i was on the sidelines holding
the clipboard for the tennessee titans i
mean you know hey there's pros and then
there's pros and it was like whoa like
we're pros out here but this guy is like
on another level i mean he was
arguably the best player i've ever seen
in my life that's how impressive adrian
peterson was in person so uh i i hear
you there that's that's a good one all
right i'm gonna go with a guy that got
on baltimore ravens this year colise
campbell i think he's got a legitimate
chance class campbell i mean it's again
i i think a hall of famer hands down
without a doubt and you know
just
always quiet always goes about his
business never heard him complain in
arizona you know was great in
jacksonville we heard so many times i
mean he was always like you know
saying something wise for the team to
latch on to or trying to help things out
in the locker room and just a pure
physical force and a guy that i know is
a good guy just from my quick
interactions with him but i've heard
people talk about him so i look at a guy
like him and root for him because of the
person and the player he is those are
always the people i root for and i think
this is what you know this draft kind of
you know uh embolizes all together
embolizes we have a new sims what the
hell is embolizes thank you
we're gonna have to save it until monday
monday on the show tomorrow yeah
embolizes envelopes
[Laughter]
real quickly i i i got some more names
frank gore
i thought about the 49ers right and
super bowl 47 you you hate frank gore
though so i can understand why you
wouldn't pick him mark ingram when you
went ravens i thought you were going
mark ingram you know he was not part of
the saints that won super bowl 44. yeah
he didn't arrive until 2011. matthew
stafford matt ryan a couple of
quarterbacks long suffering no super
bowl wins for them
andrew
julio jones andrew luck uh what the hell
see him come back and win a super bowl
that would be great and tom brady i i
was gonna almost make tom brady a pick
because i know he has six but man don't
you want to see him win one in a
different uniform no i don't really no i
don't care all right so i don't but i i
i hear i mean it is exciting uh who was
the one guy i left off my list that i
wanted to give a shout oh i did think
about carson wentz i'm not gonna lie i
know he has a ring but you know what i
mean you know because he has a phil sims
ring well yeah i get sick of that talk
all the time i mean i just do you know
so there's a part of me that would just
like to see him win it so people would
like kind of you know stop though that
conversation point all the time i don't
think it's fair
and i say that tongue-in-cheek phil sims
was a key part of the 1990 giants he
helped set the table for what was able
to come afterward when jeff hossatler
powered by an incredible defense yeah
and a game plan for the ages was able to
take down the bills in super bowl 25.
wait a rebound phil won't beat you up
now
i love phil i love
other than the fact that that you're his
child i have no complaints about phil
whatsoever
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports